perfect specimen right here baby
never made a damn mistake in my life
Christian women respect I can't I can't
joke too much in this video you may have
heard about that what happened with
Harvey Weinstein Weinstein famous
Hollywood producer now facing sexual
assault claims sexual abuse claims and
rape claims a bad person
Harvey Weinstein is a bad person sort of
putting up this feminist front you know
supporting all these charities when
really he's a piece of [ __ ] a lot of
celebrities were shocked about hearing
this news a lot of them went out to
publicly condemned Harvey rightfully so
we have Ben Affleck for example saying I
am saddened and angry that a man who I
worked with used his position of power
to intimidate sexually harass and
manipulate many women over decades thank
you Ben Affleck from one women respect
to to another think you Ben Affleck for
being a good person and standing up
against these horrible despicable acts
oh oh damn it damn it Ben Ben FAS
reporter to get them titties out
literally the day after Ben tweets I
acted inappropriately towards Miss
Burton and I sincerely apologize I agree
life comes at you fast it just swims by
sometimes one day you're a women respect
her the other day of women disrespect
her I don't even know where I'm standing
anymore life comes at you fast I was
even personally involved in a similar
sort of twisted turn of events lately I
noticed a tweet from Andy signor he was
quoting me after the Wall Street Journal
event I said I'm in no way supporting
any kind of hateful attitudes but you
are Peter pie YouTube commentators are
rotten enough without you encouraging
them
those damn YouTube commenters and
they're rotten they're rotten enough
Felix thank you Oh honest trailer
creator any signor accused of sexual
abuse oh no how did this happen why do
all these people that publicly say
they're against something do that very
same thing oh it's so weird it's almost
like it's really easy to say that you
are a good person
instead of acting like a good person
Wow who would have thought this way
easier to just tweet I respect web but
but behind closed doors is a whole
nother story
now sexual abuse sexual aside serious
things I'm not trying to make fun of it
or making light of it but it is a sort
of interesting phenomenon I literally
have a dozen example of other guys doing
this very same thing portraying this
feminist front but you know it came out
with sexual assault there's been so many
examples I'll leave a link to it I don't
want to stir up this whole thing these
people publicly condemning these things
and I'm obviously not everyone is guilty
of this but they do it because they're
afraid of being exposed themselves so
they try and distance themself as far as
possible from it
[Music]
but it's also extremely hypocritical and
personally I hate this I hate this sort
of idea that you think you're a better
than someone basically because your
phrasing it in a sentence
you know I am good and you are bad
because I would never do what you did I
am perfect okay you were terrible I
think I think the fire watch guy is a
prime example of this vanna none he
tweeted about me saying the n-word and I
think that's and I honestly I think
that's fine if you want to publicly
create I deserve to be criticized for it
the way he acted on trying to shut down
my video trying to ruin my career that's
sort of when it becomes a problem
instead of trying to communicate and
discuss when these things occur it it
often more often than not it just seems
to be a train of shame and harassment
and attacking when really it solves
nothing
to do that all you're doing is putting
yourself on a pedestal it has become so
important how people publicly perceive
you that people will act against what I
think they think is the right thing to
do because like I said it's more
important that people see you in a good
line it sort of puts morals over logic
which is a sort of becomes like a
paradox because what you think you're
doing that is immoral becomes immoral am
I making any sense here I just see a lot
of intelligent people on Twitter that
act like batshit crazy people because
they want to be perceived as good people
and I think this all stems from
self-worth especially with social media
people it's such an ocean of people how
can I stand out
how can people know that I'm important
it's sort of like it's a small example
but people putting literally what their
diet is in their Twitter bio yeah I'm
the I'm big like congratulations and I
think this sort of self-worth has
created such a divide in specially
the generation above me it's almost like
a social religion that unless you think
and act in this very specific frame of
mind then we will shut you out and we
will publicly shame you and you're not
allowed in our social group anymore but
literally all this does is having people
like Ben and Andy and so many others to
make this sort of posts because they're
afraid they are scared of being outed
they're scared of being an outcast and
they're scared of being associated with
the bad crowd I think with my generation
it's completely different and younger no
one cares
context matter more and I'm glad this is
the sort of way of thinking that will be
going forward in the future and it's I
think it's the reason why I'm even able
to keep making youtube videos I'm sure
I've been I would have been stripped
away from from it if that wasn't the
case because the majority of people on
YouTube and the majority of people
watching look doesn't look at it in this
frame of mind and I do think it's
important for the future I do think it's
important for the sake of freedom of
speech which seems to be such a blurred
line of definition these days I think if
you want a person to be punished and
afraid of saying certain things then you
have the freedom of speech of doing so
but you are also bad for doing so don't
act like these people that I mentioned
in this video and pretend that you are
somehow a better person online because
who knows life comes at you fast